-Our next guest has her comedy
album, "Salt Daddy,"
available on Apple Music.
Making her television debut,
please welcome the very funny
Katherine Blanford.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Oh! This is so cool!
Oh, my God!
Especially because I grew up
a weird kid,
and my parents wanted me
to be normal so bad.
So they made me pick a sport.
So I picked cross-country
'cause it was the closest thing
to being a horse.
It was a thing.
And then, a mile into
every race, I would remember,
"Oh, I hate running.
I'm more of a show pony."
Right?
So, I would fake pass out.
I got really good at it.
I would do a
couple little lazy twirls,
and then, on the way down,
I'd grab a girl's hair
for witness.
"Remember me."
And my mom got worried.
She was like, "Katherine,
I'm going to take you
to see a cardiologist
for your fainting,"
because my mother
believed in me too much.
And I didn't tell her
I was faking it.
I let them run
hours of tests on me.
And then this sweet little heart
doctor told my mother and I
that I was his first patient
that he ever diagnosed
with a personality disorder.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Don't clap. Don't clap.
Here's the best part, though.
He still gave me an inhaler.
He was like, "I don't know.
It could be allergies,
but it's probably narcissism.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now go ahead.
Go ahead, take a little
puff of this air milk
every time you're having
a hard time
not being
the center of attention."
And then I just became
an inhaler kid.
And inhalers are good.
They help you not lose
your breath or your virginity.
So it was a hard childhood.
But now I'm doing great.
I'm too cute -- I'm too cute
to be doing comedy.
I should be selling
medical equipment.
Before comedy,
though, I was a nanny,
because I'm passionate about
eating rich people's food.
And sometimes, the parents would
make comments about
how quickly the fridge emptied.
And I was like, "Oh, okay.
Hold on.
First of all, you don't know
how hard it is to be
a stay-at-your-home mother."
And they were a wealthy family
in the South,
so all their kids
were named after nature.
I had a Lily, I had a Forrest,
and I had a Treasure Map III.
Yeah, I was
a great nanny, though,
because I learned from
having a great mom.
And I love talking about my mom.
She passed away
when I was 22 years old.
It's hard to say
a joke after this now
because people are thinking
it's sad that I'm older than 22
and I still dress like this.
I dress like a
male figure skater from 1994.
But I still hear from my mom.
You know, I don't know if
you've ever gotten a sign
from up above,
but the other day,
I was driving down
the interstate,
just scrolling through
Instagram...
and I saw this ad for
discounted Botox.
So I just commented, "Ugh!
Okay, Mom!"
'Cause my mom was a nurse for
a plastic surgeon.
And when I was a teenager,
my mother told me
I needed Botox,
because sometimes
a mother's touch hurts.
And she would come home with
these little vials of
expired Botox,
and then she would chase me
around the
house with a syringeful.
Yeah, it was our little game.
We called it freeze tag.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Instead of counting to 10,
you just stay frozen
for three to four months.
But I am obsessed with
Instagram.
My friends and I -- we're
obsessed with those influencers
that'll go to Tulum, Mexico,
and they'll take
a yacht excursion.
So we were like,
"We've got to do that."
So we put all of
our money together
and we went...
to Fort Lauderdale.
And we wanted to take
a yacht excursion,
so we found a man
on Craigslist to take us
on his pontoon into the ocean,
where you can't run away.
And that does sound sketchy,
but we knew we were safe because
his name was Salt Daddy.
So we knew he had daughters.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I know.
He was great.
He poured us drinks
and he played us music,
and we did what good little
white girls are supposed to do.
We were twerking to Tim McGraw.
And we were feeling so cute
because Salt Daddy
was taking a lot of videos.
Just being a classic dad,
you know,
filming all the proud moments
on his iPad.
And then, right at that moment,
this huge boat pulled up,
and it was full of these
just gorgeous women.
And Salt Daddy was about to
get on their boat.
And I
realized -- I was like, "Wait.
I'm not ready for
a new mom yet."
So I pulled my best move
and I fake passed out.
But on the way down,
I for real fell overboard.
And as I was going under,
I could hear everybody
shouting my name.
And I saw Salt Daddy dive in
to save me.
And my lungs started to
fill up with water,
and then my heart
started to fill up with
all the attention I was getting.
And that's when I realized,
"Oh, I should have joined
the swim team."
Thank you so much.
I've been Katherine Blanford.
♪♪
-She believed in you too much.
-Thank you so much.
-I love that.
Katherine Blanford!
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Salt Daddy"
is available on Apple Music.
We'll be right back, everybody.